since you know every great movie begins
with the story I think we should start
with Sam uh this is based on your 2012
Play What Was sort of the initial spark
or the idea that prompted you to write
this story I first started writing this
12 13 years ago
um and I like Charlie I was teaching
expository writing at the time to
college freshmen that Rutgers both my
husband and I were uh and um like
Charlie I was really struggling to
connect with my students and at a
certain point I just kind of begged them
like Charlie does to write something
honest and one of my students wrote a
line that ended up in the play and the
film uh which was I think I need to
accept that my life isn't going to be
very exciting
um which was this kind of like brazing
moment of honesty uh and so I started
writing a play about an expository
writing teacher uh it was the first time
that I kind of got out of my own way as
a writer and was like I think I need to
just access some more personal stuff
here uh so you know I grew up in the
town where Charlie grew up I was a gay
kid there I went to a a Christian School
that was similar to where Tiger's
character comes from uh and I was gay
and I was eventually outed uh and and
had to leave
and you know that and a lot of other
things resulted in years of depression
and self-medication with food
um so you know even though nothing in
the play in the movie is
autobiographical it comes from that kind
of personal place
so Darren Aronofsky sees your play you
don't even know he's senior no idea
and he reaches out to you at some point
about making a movie yeah literally it
was just Aaron aronowsky wants to meet
with you and talk about phone rights to
the whale and similar to Sam Brendan you
get a call saying Darren Aronofsky wants
to meet with you for a role had you ever
even met or spoken to him was this just
out of the blue I didn't know Darren I
met him after he the word went out that
Mary ever knew said that Darren was
going to shoot a film and I I only knew
as much as that it was about a man who
had been living by himself for a
considerable amount of time and he had
been
having certain regrets about Life
Choices he'd made choices that life made
for him also he had been
he'd been harming himself by overeating
and
he realizes that he has very little time
and
is compelled to try and redeem himself
in his daughter's eyes who from whom he
was estranged and that's all he knew
I met Darren in his office as a protozoa
one very cold January in 2020. um he was
a gentleman and he explained it this
movie was something he didn't know if he
could make it just
by the fact that he didn't he had a
challenge ahead of him to cast the role
what he did say is
um read this I hadn't read the
screenplay
um and I went home I did I fell to
pieces I I knew this was something
compelling and truthful and it spoke to
me in ways that
um
I hadn't seen on any script that it came
across my purview ever in my career so
that made my teeth kind of sweat a
little bit because I wanted to do it
very much Darren had arranged for a
reading at is it Saint Mark's so either
Eddie St Mark thank you in the village
with music stands and some other actors
to fill out the the cast of Sadie sink
was also at the reading where she and I
met
um she had no idea who I was which is
really good
fresh fresh eyes
um
and I was knew that I'd be lucky enough
to be working with her if this came
together but then
um
it was March 2020 so
um yeah so what happens well we all put
our sweatpants on for a while
we we had to we I guess we didn't have
an answer we didn't know we had a movie
um and that was the answer and it stayed
that way for some time
made of of the amazing makeup and
Prosthetics in the in this movie and for
good cause it really enhances this
performance
um Adrian you've worked with Darren
before at what point did he approach
about this project and and let's be
honest what was your initial reaction
did you know you could do it well the
thing with Darren is that I've worked
with him a few times like I think this
is my fifth project I do with him
um
and he's Relentless he's a Relentless
perfectionist and uh he called me I
think it was in the late fall of 2020
and says I have this project
uh we want to shoot this really quickly
we want to shoot this in about five
weeks I mean I was okay well we're gonna
have to
to use a lot of uh of tricks to sort of
hide Charlie's body and maybe if we do
like just the facial Prosthetics maybe
seeing the S hands we can do something
that that we could fit within that five
weeks
uh and then I had like a a few days
later I had a another call with Darren
and he I was like so what do you want to
see we could we could hide in like that
we could hide his body he's like no no I
want to see the whole thing and there's
actually going to be a scene where he's
going to be in the in the shower nude
and I was like
five weeks
no and then and then we went back and
forth and I begged them I said like this
is the first time I ever do a movie
not enough with that kind of makeup but
where the
the main characters and Prosthetics the
entire time he's in almost every scene
if the makeup doesn't work the movie is
not going to work so I was like you
don't give me five weeks please and uh
and then we we agreed on on that and he
was super kind him and and everybody at
824 at Prada zoa and they ended up
giving me 12 weeks to build the uh the
makeup that's still not a lot it's not
it's not a lot but it's been in five
years okay true true and what was sort
of the process of perfecting it for you
and for Brandon because I know in you
know under normal conditions you'd be
working together and you'd be making
molds but this is this covid times you
weren't able to do did you even meet
until you got to the set no that's the
that's the crazy thing is that we've uh
we've been very lucky because we we live
in this day and age and we've uh we've
used a lot of 3D printing technology and
scanning in the past five six years at
the shop uh I've sent our our producer
Jeremy to meet with Brandon and his his
driveway with a 3D scanner it was an
iPad come on
I kept screwing up the scan because my
dog was running around my ankles
sorry and uh and then the following day
he sent me data it was pretty rough but
based with all the pictures that he had
taken did you just say it was pretty
rough
and it was a tale of a dog at the bottom
and uh we spent a lot of time together
and uh and so I cleaned up all that data
and when we had something that was that
was workable and we did all of the
initial designs with that until we found
the character of Charlie in 3D uh as 3D
models and then once we had that then
Darren was uh was happy with it then we
were able to refine all the all the the
models that we had until we got
something that was photo real and we
were able to 3D print from that and and
create a Prosthetics from those prints
wow
and in the meantime Brandon you're
preparing for this role not with you
don't have the Prosthetics yet but
you're talking to people you're doing
research
um can you talk about that initial
research and then when you did put the
Prosthetics on if it changed everything
I I needed to approach the text as it
would do as if I was working on one of
Sam's plays and I needed you know I
needed to get it in my head I needed I
felt like I had to have have the lines
ready for me because um
it would be too complicated
on the day and so I I spent a lot of
time really in study and my little
office space about the garage
on Zoom calls uh drilling lines and
um making the acquaintance of
some really wonderful people who are
with the Obesity Action Coalition who I
was introduced to by Dr Rachel Goldman
who
um
Advocates on their behalf it's a support
group and gets referrals
um to those who live with obesity and
their family members one thing that I I
learned above all else was
um
don't be mean don't be mean be kind
because something that they each had in
common with one another was that early
on in their lives
they were spoken to by an adult or a
parent they were really quite cruel to
the child about how they presented
themselves how how they appeared how
their body appeared and I know that
it stayed in a cycle that brought them
to the place where they are now and it
just undermined
um
the
need I had to
to be
a voice of um
of dignity and respect in playing this
role as we see with a man like Charlie
who carries the trauma that he has has
consumed on his body as a character and
it was very clear to me that that those
who live with it have a story to tell
and they deserve to have it done so at
dignity and with respect Rob I'm so
curious I believe this is your first
collaboration with Darren how did he
approach you and what was sort of your
initial response did you discuss
influences what was what was that
conversation like Darren's one of my
favorite filmmakers and so this was very
exciting and then at about 11 A.M that
morning we were zooming and Darren told
me about the film I think he was pretty
far along with the edit at that point
and uh so he told me what he had and he
said I want to send it to you and I
watched it and there was no score you
know Philip Glass talks about how
composing is actually about listening
and I really relate to that so I'm
always trying to listen to what is
trying to be said and spoken and if that
is a feel or a tone or an instrument
and um
a couple things that came through were
this overtone flute which I had heard
years before this Belgian guy makes
these overtone flutes and they kind of
sound like a didgeridoo and a flute had
a baby and uh
it's this very unearthly sound it opens
the film and the shot where the the boy
gets off on the bus it's kind of this
hollow windy sound
and
also I felt that there's a kind of um
Charlie's character is is Charlie is so
erudite and he's an intellectual in a
lot of ways and he's very well read and
the threat of Moby Dick it's there's
something mythological and allegorical
and
um kind of classical about it and I
thought you know that that that's really
the the soul of his mind in a way so to
give some breadth and depth and bring
some more classical elements and kind of
a mythological approach to the score
it's kind of making it larger than life
at times that's what I went for and the
process with Darren was really
not a lot of Converse condensing about
ideas is kind of like just chilling it
was really uh not prescriptive in terms
of of what he wanted and he really
looked to me to kind of imagine that so
we went on step by step and let some
things live in the film and there were
other scenes that were kind of tough to
crack but um
a lot of the
initial ideas that I put forth ended up
being what the what the what's in the
final before we go I just want to ask
Sam and and Brendan and we have an extra
mic in case you need it
um Sam you've been living with the story
for you know more than 10 years and
Brendan you've been living with this
character who I know is you know
incredibly personal to you
um now that the world has finally seeing
it you know what do you sort of hope
that people take away from this movie
and from Charlie
I mean I think we live in deeply cynical
times
um
and uh we might be even getting more
cynical I think we live in an era where
like cynicism
masquerades as intelligence it
masquerades as sophistication but
actually it's pretty intellectually
bankrupt in my opinion it's easy it's
perversely comforting and I think you
know this is a story and a play in a
movie that wears its heart firmly on its
sleeve it's vulnerable in that way
um but I hope that people would get a
sense of
not easy optimism but like hard one hope
uh in in Dark Times
My Hope Is that we can change some
hearts and Minds by by stories and
um
I I know I needed to gather myself the
first time I saw it I was a there was no
no score I should tell you Rob when I
when I saw it um and I was also
I felt like I was watching a movie night
um I didn't know it was in but I I was
um
I had a feeling that this could do a lot
of good
um so I felt quite confident about that
I felt good about that well again it's
in theaters now please let everyone know
thank you for being a great audience
thank you all so much thanks